what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with fall of X and we're here
with X-Men number 26 and this is gonna
have a crazy moment with Kitty Pride so
what this does is this picks up in the
aftermath of or really kind of taking
place during the time that we saw an
invincible Iron Man when Iron Man was
meeting with Emma Frost after the fall
of perkoa and the invasion of orcas and
so on and so forth what we didn't know
and what was really interesting was that
in the Invincible Iron Man Comics
suddenly Wilson fisked the Kingpin had
just become like the white king of the
hellfire club right one of the most
influential groups in the world that
would really allow him to operate in a
way that would help to safeguard the
surviving mutants on Earth in a way that
somebody just really couldn't be done by
anybody else the way this played out is
that in this moment when Tony Stark had
left Emma Frost in the sewers and
Invincible Iron Man Wilson Fisk appear
right and he really brought out this
really amazing point where he said if
they have not already orcas will move to
seize your considerable assets resources
that will be needed for our war effort
now that's one of the things to remember
orcas is a governmental organization
right they're pretty nefarious they do
some shady stuff but they are joined or
really kind of made up of all these
different groups from all these
different sectors Shield Hydra Advanced
idea mechanics the whole nine yards and
they stand as a direct opponent of any
Mutant groups or any Mutant rights that
exists out there in the Marvel Universe
with that being the case with mutants
now being branded Public Enemy Number
One they have no more rights and so
going through and taking money out of
their bank accounts seizing their assets
would be one of the first things to do
the lest we forget with Emma Frost she's
got a very very lengthy history and so
using her powers for her own ends is
something that she's done over the years
and made herself basically a millionaire
or a billionaire I don't know if Marvel
actually States how much money she has
but she does have quite a bit and so the
first thing they would do is seize all
the money she has at her disposal this
is one of the reasons or really kind of
how Wilson Fisk became the black king of
the hellfire club because what he would
be able to do is effectively move her
money from her accounts into accounts
that are owned by the hellfire club and
now it's their money not her money and
the hellfire club is not a target of
orcas and there's no way they would be
able to get a warrant to seize those
assets in the first place so it's
putting her money in a safe place it's
one of the ways in which he demonstrated
himself as being exceedingly important
to the forces of the mutants who survive
on Earth the other part of this and
unless you read secret Empire you
wouldn't know about this but it's one of
the coolest elements of Kingpin that
when secret Empire took place Captain
America conquered the United States and
so on and so forth New York was kind of
sent away to like some dark dimension
where it was very difficult for anybody
to stay alive live but Wilson Fisk
basically kept crime at Bay but he told
people in the city in exchange for
keeping you safe here all I ask is that
when the time comes you vote for me so
that when he ran to become the mayor of
New York City that guy ended up winning
because of all the people who saw him as
someone that was in their corner and so
despite the fact that he's not really
the mayor anymore he still has a vast
amount of influence the biggest rule he
has an influence is bending the courts
to his favor that's the coolest thing
right because now they have a guide that
can control or at least help to control
government on a local level that can
stand in the way of orcas basically
making a hassle for mutants within the
city of New York it's not all
encompassing he can't just turn New York
City into a safe haven for mutants but
he can do a lot to get in the way of
orcas now the other part of this is Tony
Stark while yes at the moment Tony Stark
is flat broke right the guy has no money
and of course you can find out about
that at the playlist at the end of this
video the fact is he's still an Avenger
and the Avengers are still working on
behalf of the X-Men albeit in secret and
taking pot shots because if the Avengers
come out and they say we side with the
mutant population public opinion is so
against the mutant population it would
turn on the Avengers so it would
literally make their life harder and so
in response to this Tony Stark is just
kind of like the black king of the
hellfire club and so he's kind of the
Avengers liaison to the X-Men now the
other part of this is of course Miss
Kendall that's the fake persona of Emma
Frost right it's the identity she uses
along with the ring she wears because
remember there is technology that exists
out there and we still don't know who
created it as far as I'm aware unless I
miss something we still don't know who
it was that did it but effectively
there's little pieces of jewelry you can
wear little trinkets things like that
that will mask your mutant identity so
that these Sentinels that are out there
or any artificial intelligence
technology will not be able to detect
attacked the mutant Gene and so Tony
Stark as he's here is the Playboy he's
the guy who isn't really the billionaire
anymore but people still see him with
the Devil May care you know drunk kind
of attitude that sort of thing and that
when he gets into a room with Miss
Kendall he's like thanks for the save
Emma this is dope it's really really
cool the reason why is because Tony
Stark is putting on the ACT the world
sees him as the irresponsible
billionaire guy who masquerades as Iron
Man doesn't really care about anything
other than himself behind the scenes
Tony Stark is a wholly different person
than the guy that he was back then
Society doesn't realize it and even if
they did they probably wouldn't
acknowledge it but him working alongside
Emma shows the guy he really is which is
basically this notion that he's aware of
Firestar and orcas now for those of you
guys who don't know what that means
Firestar is a mutant and at the very
beginning of fall of X when orcas
launched their strike against gracoa
before Jean Gray died she basically
modified the memories of everybody in
orcas who believed that Firestar was the
one that turned against the X-Men now
the good thing about this is that it
allowed Firestar to basically exist
within orcus and gather Intel with orcas
being none the wiser to Jean Gray's
modifications the downside to this is
every mutant in existence thinks she's a
traitor they think that she turned on
the whole mutant population and ratted
them out and so miss Kendall right Emma
Frost meeting with Tony is her asking
the question is Firestar in the orcus
facilities right is that your quote
unquote Optics right the sources of
Intel that you have within orcus and
while he won't necessarily come clean
her response is if she's your mole tell
her she's been targeted by a rogue
mutant assassin who she has no hope of
surviving if she is not your mole then
I'll go fetch and urn from the basement
and so this literally tells Tony Stark
let her know what's happening because if
you don't she's gonna die right she
needs to be able to prepare now there is
a whole thing with Miss Marvel right
Kamala Khan where she continues to do
virtually nothing within the fall of X
stories right she's literally just been
useless the entire higher time right and
I don't say that because I hate her
character I say it because like she's
literally been doing nothing the entire
time like literally just doing nothing
at all and so what we end up doing is we
jump to What's called the bloom right
orcas's space station above Earth and we
pick up with Kitty pride and I know you
guys love kitty Pride you guys love what
Marvel's been doing with Kitty Pride
during fall of X and I do too man I
absolutely love what they've been doing
with their character because she's just
so deadly now right like she's like the
deadliest mutant in Marvel Comics one of
the things that she's done here right
just to show how far her powers go and
what she's capable of she's been stowing
away in the hole of a ship and what
she's been doing is using scuba gear so
she can breathe oxygen to keep herself
alive lest she ends up succumbing to the
vacuum of space and essentially dies
right as soon as she gets into the orcas
facility as you would expect all the
alarms go off and she expected exactly
that right like she had planned multiple
Escape Routes all that stuff Kitty Pride
the Assassin is dope Firestar in her
cell comes to the realization after
being contacted by Tony Stark that
basically Kitty Pride doesn't know about
Jeannie Gray's tampering so as far as
Kitty pride is concerned she's here to
kill a traitorous X-Man and that's it
right now here's one of the coolest
things Kitty Pride does because you guys
love to see all the different ingenious
ways that she kills people which is
pretty dope I mean hey let's be honest
with ourselves right it's pretty solid
like once she gets in here she breaks
the neck of one of the guards that runs
up on her then she grabs the other guy
right knocks him off his feet grabs him
by the foot drops him through the hole
of the ship except she makes him
re-solidify halfway through he gets cut
in half so like his upper torso is just
drifting through the vacuum of space
it's hardcore man I'll be honest with
you guys when we get kitty pride in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe this is the
one that I kind of don't want to see
right I want to see just like the
assassin murderous Kitty Pride you never
really get to see her all that often in
Marvel Comics and it's so awesome to see
her here and so with her standing
outside the cell of Firestar Firestar
initially addresses her right like kitty
Pride like if you're outside that door I
need to talk I have a crazy story to
tell you kitty Pride literally holds her
breath phases herself through the hole
of the ship makes herself intangible
comes around to the other side and
attacks Fire Star right like I mean this
is how deadly this girl is and that's
what's so cool is because Firestar tries
to explain what's going on she of course
turns into her flaming form which
basically makes her intangible right so
Kitty Pride can't really kill her using
her sword or anything like that so
they're basically at a stalemate right
and so that's when Firestar is like look
at the gala when it was clear we'd lost
Jean Gray telepathically inserted
memories into stasis head about
recruiting me and being a dub agents so
I could help whoever survived in
whatever way I could and before she
could tell anybody else she died and now
I'm here alone trying to do what I can
and I didn't ask for this but Gene did
it anyway and said I had to volunteer
but I didn't really even volunteer and I
didn't even want to be an X-Man but now
I am I know that I can be important I
can be of service I am a mutant and I'm
proud I resist right it's some straight
up John Wick stuff I will serve I will
be of service like it's a really cool
thing and so in response to this you
have her asking the question of kitty
Pride I know you don't believe me but
you have to believe that all of this is
true kitty Pride's response that's the
most Gene gray thing that Jean Gray
would ever do and it's true right it's
like the most Jean Gray thing she's done
that multiple times over the years
because one of the things to forget is
that kitty pride has been part of the
X-Men ever since she was like like a
preteen right when she was like 13 14 15
years old she's been in the X-Men for an
incredibly long time longer than she
hasn't been in the X-Men she's
experienced virtually everything that
you can experience being an X-Man is why
she led her own X-Men team at one point
along the line is how she's become so
deadly and so knowing Jean Gray as well
as she does she's like yeah that makes
perfect sense now of course she tells
her like the final punch was to
basically just make the whole thing look
good you know so on and so forth but
where Firestar asks the question who
else survived the response of kitty
pride is I don't know and even if I did
I wouldn't tell you she's playing it
safe here right it's not a lack of trust
it's the fact that when you have any
kind of organized resistance you never
want to have one person who knows
everything because all you have to do is
get a hold of that one person and the
entire resistance forts come crashing
down so it's better to compartmentalize
it all Iron Man knows some stuff Emma
Frost knows some stuff Kingpin knows
some stuff Kitty Pride knows some stuff
and and that's it right like no one
knows everything it's like what Nick
Fury said in the Winter Soldier right
like no one has all the pieces and so
it's really really awesome to see her
functioning in this way because she's
just one piece of a much bigger system
she even goes so far as to tell Firestar
don't take it personally right it's just
the way that you run an effective
resistance but even when Firestar asks
the question like will you tell
everybody else out there that I'm on
their side the response of kitty Pride
yet again predicting the most
intelligent route is to say no because
the best thing for your cover is to have
X-Men trying to take pot shots at you
and trying to kill you and she says
because lest you forget you're
considered a traitor by every X-Man in
existence right every mutant that
survived in existence how strange would
it be if in the midst of all of this no
one who is a mutant tried to kill you
for your traitor's actions orcas would
start asking questions because they're
not dumb they're incredibly intelligent
and they would figure out that something
was off then they started doing mental
scans then they start realizing their
memories have been meddled with right so
the safest thing for you to do is to
basically just stay here and treat every
instance where an X-Man or any Mutant
out there that tries to kill you is
basically just part of your training
because you know that's just what you're
gonna have to contend with and so
following that you have a meet up
between Kitty pride and Emma Frost now
this is incredibly important here and
the reason why is because when the alert
was sent to Firestar by Tony Stark the
concern of Emma Frost was that basically
it wouldn't get there soon enough and
that kitty Pride would end up killing
Firestar Kitty Pride showing up here and
basically saying no like everything's
cool everything is copacetic Tony
Stark's information coming from Firestar
and orcas will remain intact because
that's its source right that's his mole
in orcas it's Firestar she's the one
that feeds him information right I
understand what's going on now I get
everything that's happening I won't try
to kill her again the next question that
Emma Frost has is what's going on with
Cyclops because for those of you guys
who don't remember soccer is alive but
he was taking taken by orcas his eyes
were sewn shut in a pretty gruesome way
so he can't fire his optic blast but we
don't fully know what they intend to do
with him presumably they intend to like
Harvest his DNA make different
duplicates out of him if sinister's
motivation or at least Dr stasis
motivation being a clone of sinister if
it's the same as it always was his goal
is to use the genetic material of
Cyclops to produce some kind of uber
mutant that he could use to wipe out all
the other mutants in existence right
that was the nature of Nate gray X-Man
and Marvel Comics back in the 90s sure
he wasn't designed to kill every mutant
in existence but he was astronomically
powerful one of the most powerful
mutants to ever exist in the history of
Marvel Comics right so again there's a
lot of possibility here but the issue is
that Emma Frost wants to know where
Cyclops is and so because of that she
agrees to team up with Kitty Pride the
two of them will go on a mission
together and they will try to find
Cyclops and kill whoever's in their path
and I'll be honest with with you guys
Kitty Pride with what she's capable of
teaming up with one of the most powerful
telepaths in existence in Omega Level
telepath they would take all comers
right they would annihilate anybody who
stands in their way what's crazy about
this is that when Emma Frost goes back
into the hellfire club to meet with Tony
Stark to tell him what she intends to do
she sees fei-long right why does FEI
Long matter because he's the guy that
basically took over Stark Industries and
turned the Iron Man armor suits into
Sentinels that were tasked with tracking
down mutants she hates this guy she
despises this guy right she sees this
guy as really the most hated enemy she
has in the here and now there's more
hated enemies than him but it's the guy
that she seemingly hates the most at the
moment Tony Stark snatches her up pulls
her to the side and says look I totally
get that you've seen this guy here is a
shock but here's the thing that guy's
got information that I need and you are
a telepath he doesn't know that you're a
talent a path the ring on your finger
simply blocks them from being able to
track your mutant signature it does not
take away your powers so what I need you
to do is go out there as your normal
self scan that guy's mind right break
through any mental blocks that he may
have and give me the information that I
need because what Tony Stark is doing
secretly behind the scenes is building a
ridiculously overpowered Iron Man suit
that would allow him to take on pretty
much all of these Sentinels but it takes
time and he needs to know the ins and
outs of how the Sentinels function in
order to build his Iron Man suit in a
way that can overcome the power of the
Sentinels and fail them the problem here
is that she goes to take off a ring she
needs Iron Man in the gut and then when
FEI Long happens to walk in it looks
like he's proposing to her and so in
response to this Emma Frost contacts
Kitty pride and says hey something came
up I'm sorry I'm not going to be able to
join you the response of cutie pride is
me too because for Kitty Pride this is a
feeling of betrayal right it's another
end since where she's just kind of left
out there on her own and so it's a huge
moment for a character because now
potentially Emma Frost and Tony Stark
have made themselves enemies of kitty
pride and God helped their souls if she
decides to come after them with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end if you need to get caught up
on fall of X make sure you guys click
this link to the playlist and I will
catch you all later
peace